thank you very much for the introduction
and for inviting me to the workshop so
the motivation for this talk is
obviously learning graphical models as
the title indicates but the goal is to
learn subject to a different criterion
than is typical so we'll see
specifically what that is this is joint
work with Mina cars and use a student at
MIT ok so to motivate the the talk we're
talking about learning graphical models
and although once you have a graphical
model you can do a lot of nice things
like run mcmc and compute posteriors
which is of interest in machine learning
often you don't have the model ok so
what you have is something like this you
just have some giant matrix of data what
you would like is a model ok so what you
want is to go from there to here and
that's what we'll be talking about ok um
so roughly at kind of a high level there
are two goals when you would like to
learn a graphical model the first one is
or the obvious one can we learn the
actual structure right there are some
actual connections between neurons can
we figure what those are from the data
people are actually friends on Facebook
can we observe some some data or maybe
they might actually be friends in real
life too so that's also possible but can
we figure that out from some
observational data it's that's sort of
the first goal and there's been a
tremendous amount of work on this but I
won't really go into detail at this
point on second question which is
natural for machine learning people is
how do you learn a model to then make
predictions I want to predict whether
you're going to like a YouTube video or
something similar or I don't care what
the actual model is necessarily and
that's more so the focus of this talk ok
so just to motivate this even a little
more light so one application is medical
diagnosis and people actually use the
sort of model for for medical diagnosis
the idea someone comes to the ER they're
feeling unwell and specifically maybe
their chest hurts and you wanna figure
out do they have a heart attack so then
obviously want to take care of that or
do they have heartburn and maybe you
should give them some antacid and send
them home so you collect a bunch of kind
of information about them they say
they're tired the heart rate and so on
if you had a model then you could for
example round loop EVP and figure out
what's the posterior probability of them
having each of these situations I guess
what we care about and Jen
all of these posteriors now having
actual number for the posterior is
useful because if you get some really
invasive unpleasant procedure performed
on you when actually just a part burn
you probably be unhappy it turns out
people are actually unhappy the other
direction happens as well when they
actually the heart attack in there sent
home they don't like that so so so is we
want to figure out these posteriors
accurately and actually help doctors
figure out what to do right um probably
less dramatic unless kind of
fundamentally important to your health
depending of course on how much you
suffer from bad recommendations on
Amazon and so on you might have a
similar situation where you'd like to
from collection of ratings of people
predict the likelihood that you're going
to buy or or like an item that you have
not yet purchased derated right and so
once again if we had a model specifying
the joint distribution over all these
items that would be useful ok so the
mathematical problem is you have some
model in our case I'm going to be
interested in izing models we use P here
to denote the number of variables so
it's a p-dimensional plus 1 minus 1
vector people like p at statistics so
you'll have to forgive me if you're used
to n you observe a bunch of data so M
samples each sample is a full vector and
P dimensions and the goal is to learn a
model okay now I'm starting with the
more traditional learn the model goal
and we'll switch that in a moment so
specifically the goal is can we learn
the graph that underlies the model from
the data and we thought this probability
going to one yeah so let's quickly
review if you kind of results in that
direction and then do that'll give
context or the other question yes please
CSS you learn that means learning all
the fee to IJ essentially
we said of the growth good so learning
the graph would just be the support of
the Fate I Jase so which edges are there
and which are not there it turns out
actually that once you know the graph
learning the actual theta IJ is very
easy if the graph is sparse if the
degree is bounded by D then it's you can
just do just a congressional you know
them its neighborhood and figure out the
theta I JS yes for this problem the
combinatorial problems learning the
graph okay so first basic result in
terms of kind of framing ourselves is
what's the sample complexity of this
problem how many samples do Union right
so in that context Prasad sometime and
Martin Wainwright gave a result and that
that has the right dependence on the
parameter strength so I'm going to
assume that the parameters maybe I even
wrote something here I didn't write it
here so if the parameters are bounded
between alpha and beta the difficulty of
this task depends on those okay now
their basic construction was to start
with the click on D plus 1 vertices if I
have degree D and ideas as you all kind
of know for a ferromagnetic model it's
typical situation is the most of them
are plus for most of the remaining in
the situation if theta is big edge
strength is big in this case it's
convince yourself it's kind of difficult
to tell if i remove an edge ok and in
particular the KL divergence between the
models is going to be small and that
gives you a lower bound right away on
the number of samples that you need in
order to learn in the graph now if I
have many copies of these clicks then
you get an extra log P factor in the
sample complexity it turns out that this
lower bound is actually basically tie it
if I'm willing to do the maximum
likelihood search over all possible
graphs yeah ok so you might ask is this
good or bad well it is what it is but
obviously you don't want to spend this
much computational expense to search
over all graphs
okay so we want to do something better
one thing that you can do and this is
from a joint paper with epsilon Mallon
is you can use the fact that your data
is coming from mark of random field and
sparse one so if the degree is bounded
by D shouldn't be that expensive to
search over neighborhoods and somehow
detect that from the conditional
independence in the model and so you can
do that there are P to SD neighborhoods
size d they give you an algorithm the
sample complexity is roughly the same
except for I'm kind of off by constants
here in terms of the dependence and
power so it's polynomial in the correct
dependence and alpha and beta okay and
the complexity is now polynomial for a
fixed D so this is good it's much less
expensive computationally sample
complexity didn't get much worse you can
still ask can we do even better than
Pete of the D if d is 20 then this is
still expensive so just briefly turns
out that you can this is from paper of
mine from last year it turns out you can
learn the graph and quadratic time okay
so time p squared there's a log peeler
as well Oh tilde and the number of
samples is some constant times log P
which I'll get to in a second what that
constant is so in a nutshell what's the
algorithm well it depends on this is
fact that sort of an
information-theoretic fact that's true
for izing models which is that for any
node in the model there's always some
node that has a mutual information
that's pretty high with that node and
that continues to hold even if you
condition on arbitrary other sub set of
nodes which note it is that has a high
mutual information might be different in
that in that case depending on what you
condition on it so from this it follows
that a greedy algorithm which is
greedily adds nodes one by one will find
the correct graph sorry found the
correct neighborhood for each node and
and that's doable in quadratic time okay
so I sort of put the constant under the
rug turns out that this lower bound and
mutual information so how much is this
non-trivial mutual information is very
small very small when I measured in
terms of alpha and beta and so then the
resulting sample complexity here is
p to the e to the beta times d times a
constant and that's double exponential
which is in case it's not obvious that's
really big so so it's exponentially
worse than then the lower bound in terms
of the parameters alpha and beta it's
all this all this discussion sort of
motivates the question why are we trying
to learn the correct graph maybe in some
of these applications like predicting
whether you have a heart attack doesn't
matter whether which variables for
example causally influence one another
the only thing that matters is I want to
make predictions accurately and maybe we
can get by with far fewer samples than
is required to guarantee these results
late and quality for a second this one
yeah sure so this is the mutual
information between X I which is this
green node and it's saying some neighbor
here in purple is going to be lower
bounded by this constant and the point
is that the constant doesn't depend on P
the number of variables in the model so
for all I there exists for all either
exists some neighbor you with a
conditional mutual information so the
more precise statement is conditioning
some arbitrary subset of nodes for a
variable that you have not conditioned
on its entire neighborhood there must
exist some neighbor with a non-trivial
mutual information
we're not trivial means I'm trivial
means satisfies this inequality yeah
okay okay good so this is really big we
want to have a lower sample complexity
to learn a model okay um so we're back
to our sort of setup we have samples
from model ya know that found the right
thing isn't good is the bound tight this
is in the worst case i mean this d
squared it's actually d squared here it
should be d & 8 here shouldn't be there
but it is actually exponentially small
if you think about say a click and your
condition on all the neighbors but one
in a ferromagnetic model it's going to
be this small well the DMV squared is
very different so is it these critters
would be i means it should be but you
will be square I can prove d squared I
think the correct answer is d but but in
hopefully hopefully yeah one would like
to believe that it's that it's d that's
right absolutely and regardless though
you're going to get so I should have
even written d squared here but double
exponential in D&D squirt are both
tremendously big I mean I agree that
they're not good you know what this
Court is significantly worse but it's
true yeah eiffel towering everest are
both tall but it still it's here it's
true
okay in here for oil conditioning all
the this condition this is for all
conditioning this is a fantastic
question I suspect it's much better I
one conjecture that's maybe don't have
that much evidence for but I suspect a
few condition on even just say one or
two notes that there exists one or two
no to you conditioned and it's pretty
big that would need to be made more
precise though okay good so let's change
the question right let's not learn the
graph learning the graph is challenging
there's too many samples so instead
let's learn a model that has accurate
posteriors which will allow you to make
predictions okay so I'll just review a
couple works that go in this direction
there's a paper by peter abeel
definitely color nine drink were they
guarantee that the model they learn is
closed and KL divergence to the true
mult where you look at the KL divergence
over the whole joint distribution you
could ask well what guarantees does that
give you as far as computing accurate
posteriors when you condition on a small
subset and the answer is not a very good
guarantee so essentially restricting or
sort of the kale over the whole joint is
a very stringent condition and to get a
small KO if you want this to be smaller
than epsilon then the number of samples
you need grows polynomial e in the
number of variables instead of
logarithmic lee so it's a it's very
expensive to get a kale that's joint
it's generally small over all the
variables okay so that's that's fine and
in some sense the reason for this is
that the whole analysis is based on
learning the correct model sort of a
analyze what happens when you're
slightly off from the correct model and
bound the worst-case error that that
could cause in the kale okay so that's
one or Saul there's actually another
result it's much closer along the ones
of what we're going for which is a
result of paper of Hyneman and Globus
inform ICML a couple years ago and they
are motivated exactly by the same
questions they want to be able to
compute posteriors accurately they asked
well what models can we compute
posteriors accurately for well we can
run BP on large growth graphs with
correlation decay
so let's try to learn those because then
we can at least are guaranteed that the
computations are going to give the right
thing those models are easy to learn
more or less and so they can guarantee
essentially that you get the right graph
maybe with a few little weak edges that
are additional and again this gives some
bound on the KL which is translated into
a bound for posteriors conditional and
small subsets logarithmic Corinthian ok
log in
good now the guarantee that they
actually get is pretty pessimistic
because again they sort of go through
this route of guaranteeing the third
graph that they get is correct so from a
more technical point of view the
motivation for this is can we bypass
this requirement and analysis of getting
the right graph in order to guarantee
correct posteriors can we have wildly
wrong graphs and still get accurate
posterior okay yes I won't go into the
details on exactly what they get so to
that end let's look at a sort of natural
notion of distance between distributions
it's not KL over the whole joint it's
not total variation over the whole joint
we care about posteriors condition on
small subsets so let's have an
appropriate notion of distance and the
one for that is the supreme over all
subsets of some size k think like three
of the total variation between the
marginal on the set between your
predicted distribution P and the true
distribution q vice versa and you can
think about it for you know five seconds
and see that this will allow you to
compute the posteriors accurately ruby
is wrong okay this is so this is exactly
the correct notion of distance in order
to guarantee what we're interested in
okay that's a good question so maybe I
should have pushed that under the rug
that they aren't always small but I
think often they're small I mean you
perform some 10 tests on someone you
aren't yes testing every possible thing
you could imagine testing yeah so it's a
good question i mean just how small it
might depend on the situation yeah okay
so in this talk actually we're going to
think about really small sets we're
going to look at two which means you
have given one thing and you would like
to predict one other thing but in
general of course you can look at bigger
ones and we're also going to restrict to
trees so not even locally tree like just
outright trees in order to try to probe
this question a little further it turns
out as far as I know these answers are
not known and then in this super simple
situation okay so just to recap a few
things that probably all of you know
just a fixed notation we have a tree
then of course the correlation across
that edge is
tangent hyperbolic tangent of the
parameter we have no external field so
this makes things easier if I want to
compute the correlation between too far
apart nodes I just multiply the
correlations across the path connecting
them now the idea is that we have some
other tree the we have some estimated
parameters theta tilde and again the
correlation and predicted model is this
hyperbolic tangent of theta tilde and
again the correlation is that along the
path if they're far apart notes now the
point and this is what makes it
interesting is that these pads could be
very different I keep saying so so how
do we produce a guarantee on how
accurate is the marginal we computed
according to two different paths that's
really a question that will focus on for
the rest of the talk okay so concretely
I had this sort of more complicated
distance between distributions but for
our purposes the only thing that matters
is that the marginals or the
correlations between pairs of variables
are accurate and that's what we're
looking at so the supreme over all pairs
are the max we're all pairs of the
deviation in the correlations okay so
we're going to embark on a little quest
to try to find the right answer I won't
quite get there but we're going to plot
our progress along this axis so we're
measuring here sample complexity
normalized by log B everything is larger
than they can be and we'll just start
throwing darts at this board and see
where we can get okay so let's start
with the question of why not just learn
the tree exactly and we'll see what that
does okay and we know of course the
trees can be learned easily when you
fully observe all the notes that's
possible due to the child lu algorithm
okay so let's see what cha Lu does yeah
so so what is chalu for those who
haven't seen it a simple idea you just
compute the empirical mutual
informations or empirical correlations
between every pair of course you don't
know the tree so what you do is you one
by one add the edges according to the
maximum weight unless for some reason
you would like to close a cycle and you
choose not to do that because you know
you have a treat to begin with okay so
this is Chris calls greedy algorithm it
gives you the max
expanding tree so you eventually end up
with a tree now you can ask well when is
it the right tree so it's possible to
analyze this pretty easily it turns out
that the number of samples you need is e
to the 2 beta over alpha squared times
log P essentially the analysis comes
from thinking about when's is this
greedy algorithm add an incorrect edge
and so there has to be some edges it
stronger than some other one and you can
sort of bound that deviation this is
actually tight so it's easy to prove
also a lower bound that says this is the
right answer fine so we can learn the
right tree what does that tell us for
predictions right because predictions
are what we care about okay so in order
to make predictions I should tell you
how to specify the parameters just
learning the tree isn't enough so the
way to specify the parameters just to
match the moments across the edges and
this turns out to be the maximum
likelihood distribution fixed to that
tree and it's equivalent to thinking
about an information projection sort of
minimizing KL divergence okay so this is
a recipe for producing a model how well
does it do well it's the number of
samples is at least to this e to the 2
beta over alpha squared the maximum of
that and one over a 2 squared times log
P you can get a bound of ADA on this
deviation of the correlations so who
knows if this is even good or bad or
what this means well see in a moment
that it's not very good one kind of
reason why it's not very good is that
first of all it depends on Alpha in a
pretty severe way so alpha is a lower
bound in the strength of the edges the
edges are super weak it's kind of
dissatisfying that this it causes the
predictions to be far from the truth
right if you think about just two
variables and there's an edge the edge
is really weak then who cares if the
edge is there or not and so it's easy to
make predictions actually they're almost
independent okay so i'll just quickly
proved this because we use that in a
moment so assume that t is equal to t
tilde so that you're able to learn the
correct tree using childhood okay let's
see how do we bound the correlation
between some arbitrary pair W and W
tilde alright so just the the quick
sketch of the argument is that there's a
telescoping some argument
and get a sum of martingale increments
and therefore get concentration of the
air along the path the one thing that's
kind of noteworthy is that it doesn't
matter how many things you're
multiplying it doesn't the accuracy is
just independent of the scale of them
all good and that gives and that gives
the correct answer in that case so the
first term in the max which will plot
here came from the requirement that you
learn the correct tree the second one
just came from I know the tree can I get
the correct marginals pairwise marginals
okay so as I said this is dissatisfying
why should it depend on the the weakness
of the edge okay so the next thing to
ask is well why do I care about the week
edges and this is an approach that many
people have taken and there's
communities including graphical model
learning sort of fully observed and also
in phylogenetic reconstruction and
rescue form and this audience have
papers on that and it's very natural
question if that just so weak let's
forget about it so so let's look at an
example and it's not sort of the idea is
is simple if this edge is very weak and
it's hard for me to guarantee that I'm
correctly recovering it let's just leave
it out and that instantly gives rise to
a pound of course the question is at
what threshold should I leave it out and
that strength is sort of accuracy of the
marginal and I'm shooting for I'm
shooting for accuracy Ada and the
marginals I shouldn't truncate edges
that are stronger than ADA because that
will introduce too big of an error I
might as well truncate edges there that
week below ADA so so that's what you can
do you can just plug in here alpha Zeta
and now effectively you have a model
where the weakest edge is strength ada
right because you just forgot about all
the weaker edges that gives us exactly
the same guarantee with alpha replaced
by ADA so we can go back here and we we
get something it seems better it doesn't
depend on alpha ok now you can still ask
well can we do something better all
right because this fundamentally is
depending on this this idea of learning
at least a correct forest every edge of
the I'm learning is a tree
and so can we avoid that requirement ok
so the source starting point is an
observation about what cha Lu does and
there's an example that contains much of
intuition so we'll go through that
example okay so what's the example we
have this model one edge is very strong
white edge is quite weak you get samples
from it and you compute the empirical
correlations so here the empirical
correlation is point 02 and here it's a
point oh eight sorry point 0 18 that's
incorrect okay so this is these are the
true correlations and the point is that
you you have an error in the trick
correlation so what you get is point of
17 in point 019 and so the the incorrect
edge is a stronger correlation in the
true edge right so if you were to just
run chalu you would add an incorrect
edge now truncating the week edges as we
saw as a natural idea the child Lou tree
on the other hand as i said adds the
wrong edge finally if i compute all the
correlations using the child lou tree
which is the wrong tree we get this ok
so let's compare how well is this doing
which is the distribution using the
wrong tree to the one where I truncated
the weekend is right so obviously the
week edges that I truncated F
correlations 0 what we see of course is
that the even though we added a wrong
edge the correlation between one and two
is actually not very far from the truth
alright so something it seems seemingly
trivial the kind of interesting has
happened which is that adding some raw
edges has led to a huge improvement in
the performance of under the model
okay so what are some have leverage this
intuition to get a result more general
setting okay so good so the the result
is this it's that if the number of
samples is at least the maximum of e to
the 2 beta + 1 / a2 squared times log P
then you can guarantee that the
marginals are accurate to within ADA so
this is better than the previous result
which is the product of the two now we
just have the maximum of the two
okay okay so i'll give it a proof of
this results or the sketch of the proof
and we'll see some of the main ideas so
the first step is to use triangle
inequality this thing turns out but it's
still satisfies triangle inequality even
though you're taking a soup so we can
more usually deal with two separate
terms one of them is sort of the
incorrect stree one of them is the child
lou tree and one of them's the correct
tree but the distribution is the same
and then the second term has the same
incorrect street the two different
distributions one is the true
distribution one's the distribution from
samples we're going to separately bound
each of these that's easier okay so
let's start with the second one so we
have the same wrong distribution one of
them were projecting onto the true tree
so there's sorry right ok so the same
incorrect treating two different
distributions one is the truth and one
is from samples I want to understand
does projecting onto the wrong trace
with ruined our distribution so let's
get an intuition for that so one basic
observation about what chalu is doing
you can ask us when does it make a
mistake ok it turns out that that will
help us to quantify the strength of
edges when we make a mistake so the
situation is again the sort of length 3
Markov chain the correlation between one
and two is mu let's make the correlation
between two and three tench beta so it's
the strongest edge possible I want to
get a bound on miu so chalu makes a
mistake if the correlation between one
and three is bigger than the correlation
between one and two and so now if you
get enough samples so that so the
deviation of each correlation is epsilon
this immediately gives you about so we
can write it down and we can define an
edge to be strong if the opposite is
true ok so this gives us sort of the
threshold for edges that we're sure are
correctly reconstructed by childhood and
of course this number is just some
number i mean it could be point 6 it's
not like super strong or anything like
that right so there's some number where
if the correlation and the true model is
above that then with high probability we
we
over those edges again and it turns out
that you can do something a little more
delicate and get a square root there in
the denominator but it doesn't matter
too much ok so we want to use this to
argue about what happens to the
correlation when we project onto the
incorrect path so let's think about some
fixed W and W tilde here in solid line
going directly is the true tree the
dotted dashed line is the incorrect
three what we know is that there are
these segments of strong edges where
they're equal ok that's sort of by the
previous slide you could differ of
course I'm the somewhat weaker edges
they're not super weak edges they're
just a little bit weaker so how do we
use this to to bound the deviation in
correlation end to end well if there was
just one strong segment and no weekend
jizz then the previous result that said
that when the true tree is equal to the
tableau tree the court that error is
small that would suffice that would
apply here so here we can almost do the
same thing we can say that the error on
each of these segments regardless of the
length is at most a DA of course there
are a bunch of them so they're getting
added up luckily that cancels out with
the somewhat weak edges there that are
going through these sort of deviations
along along the path and the total
entender is again just a de so those
effects more or less exactly cancel on
ok so that that gives us the bound that
we wanted on the correlation for the
second term I didn't emphasize this but
maybe it's maybe it's clear we're just
looking at the product of correlations
along paths in the same tree in this
example so in a moment we need to look
at what happens when you have a
different tree and this is the case
that's somewhat more interesting and
more challenging as well ok so
so let's see how the argument works
there's sort of a basic lemma that makes
things work and I won't talk about how
to prove it and surprisingly challenging
to prove and maybe someone here as an
obvious way to prove it so that would be
interesting to you can tell us but it's
a purely combinatorial fact that has
nothing to do with with any property
that these data are coming from samples
all it says is if you look at two
variables W&W tilt or two nodes and you
consider two spanning trees on the set
of nodes t and t tilde AT&T t hat here
suppose that the path between w and w
tilde are not the same okay so there are
two different paths then there exists a
pair of edges that satisfy some nice
properties okay so what are these
properties well so here we've drawn this
path we have the solid path and a dashed
path what it says that there exists a an
edge F in the solid path that's not in
the dotted train in without a tree so
it's not in t hat there's this G here
that's in the dotted path but it's not
in the solid tree but moreover than more
important is that F lies on the path
between the endpoints of G in one of the
trees and GUI Xin the path between nine
points of F and other tree so this turns
out to be true you sort of special
paired edges and we use that to bound
the error between wnw tilma so
essentially this allows to quantify the
relationship between the correlation on
g and the correlation on F then to do an
induction that founds the error between
WN w tilde in terms of the air on g the
air between W and W and V and the error
between V tilde and W tilde and so each
of these paths is shorter in length and
so you can apply an induction what's
important is that this is actually
getting multiplied by mu F so there's
this sort of a lot of work that went
into to getting this extra
multiplicative factor otherwise the
recursion wouldn't
work out so that's true because of this
paired edge lemma good so I won't get
into more details right now about the
proof on this but turns out that
actually works out if you think about it
for a little while you'll see that one
over a 2 squared is an obvious lower
bound because even if I just want to get
the correlations accurate on each of the
edges and you I need want to rate a
squared log P samples right so so
there's a gap right now and that's I
guess the tantalizing question to me is
which one's the right answer can you get
something that's independent of the
strength of the the maximum strength of
edges or not people have ideas we're
happy to hear them this whole talk was
about k equals 2 I don't know how to say
very much for k is greater equal to
three you think that maybe you can use
some tree recursions or something but it
seems to be more delicate than that to
get the right answer so that's still
ongoing work and I'll in there
very much got um any questions